now let's uh let's do Alex we haven't
done Alex in a minute right all right
Alex it is
oh this was Donald Trump
at the moment of truth and [ __ ] all over
everybody
call for Donald Trump [ __ ] him [ __ ] his
family [ __ ] all these people all right
see I shouldn't even be alive right now
when are we going on the satellite I
love him
I love Winnie girls answer nobody appear
in this goddamn [ __ ] world
not I'm [ __ ] pissed right now in the
goddamn [ __ ] liberal fascist
censoring us everywhere the last two
days we did an emergency [ __ ] 36 hour
broadcast trying to stop this [ __ ] and
you [ __ ] liberal pieces of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] support
this [ __ ] you you [ __ ] goddamn
degenerate thoughts
so I posted that a while back it seems
mad
I when I when I originally opposed Jim
Edwards sent this to me and I originally
like him I thought it was like a newer
clip this is from when they bombed Syria
or whatever but it's still
when I saw this clip the other day I
felt it I felt every word of it I was
like man like it's so relevant today but
God damn is that a great clip yeah
[ __ ] run I shouldn't be on
there right now when the [ __ ] are we
going live I can't do this
[ __ ] Trump and [ __ ] these [ __ ] people
at a certain point man I'm sick of all
you [ __ ] liberals and mainlands
you're a bunch of cowardly [ __ ] you're
not Americans what's going on
okay we're ready to go live okay
is the quivering voice of that
production terrified the producer is one
of the funniest things I've ever heard
about do you want to go live
I love that but it's so like honestly
every every word of that is true now
um
so it worked I I really think the worst
thing Alex ever did was
get into bed with Trump Alex should have
just stayed don't trust the government
guy he should have stayed the same way
through Trump that he's been his whole
career which is Donald Trump Bush yes
people are you know what I mean you
can't trust anybody's agenda and he got
so on to Trump and lost everything and
he's lost his platform he's lost his
channel he's losing listeners now he's
losing like he's lost a lot over this
and uh my favorite part of that video
though is [ __ ] Donald Trump and [ __ ] his
family I was like yes yes
[Laughter]
this is a little more topical this is um
this is from I think last month not yet
this is It's Yuki this is from last
month
um this is uh him talking about what
happened with David Knight by fraud
and they now want to start a fight but
like Martin Luther King or Mahatma
Gandhi or who they were imitating Jesus
of Nazareth we need to be non-violent at
this point because that's what exposes
them as the thugs they are not giving me
images if they got at a very limited
level at the Capitol they intended to
get citizens from all over to militarily
storm it
and uh quote citizens arrest the
Democrats that have been a hostage
situation
that would have allowed the 25th
Amendment the president and or impeach
him and bring in total tyranny thank God
the Patriots fought and battled with the
antifa and the Q people that were
totally under mind control not all cue
people are bad a lot of folks get into
it because it's fun like an Easter egg
hunt or whatever a treasure hunt
but a lot of folks don't get the larger
picture of how they're using augmented
reality online to manipulate you in the
real world now it's a globalist
operation remember Trump was invincible
couldn't be beat Jeff sessions was great
Hillary was in gitmo uh Bill Barr was
great none of it was true folks but they
know you want good news
I could make stuff up and have a super
viral all day that was something about
David Knight and I really like David you
can do whatever he wanted he asked me to
hire his second son uh you know
basically to run a website for them just
to promote his stuff alone and
he didn't like the cue stuff
and we'd have a few guests on here and
there that would kind of promote that
and then he would say Jones is having
these people on I
and I'm like I don't agree with what
those people are saying
and then he's like well I'm going to
quit I mean I can't be around this I'm
going to get fired is this about that
John what's his face guy I'm not really
sure because there was a clip that Adam
green posted on um
on Twitter and um
you know his angle is spoiler alert
um but he posted a clip of this John
something or other guy who's a q Anon
dude
and he basically like admitted live on
Infowars like yeah we were putting stuff
out because we needed you guys to get
that message out but it was like
basically admitting that he's full of
[ __ ] and like I think I'm wondering
because that is I forget the guy's name
I'm sure somebody in the chat can can um
probably tell me who the guy John P
piece nick uh Steve peace Nick no that's
the guy it's not John Steve Steve peace
Nick that that's the guy sorry it's not
wasn't John so this Steve guy kept going
on Infowars and pushing cue [ __ ] and he
was doing a lot of the cracking stuff
and you know doing a lot of that even
though most the Infowars people were
kind of like yeah I don't whatever but
Alex was letting this guy on and then it
was like a thing where the guy went on
to
Infowars again and he goes yeah I
basically like more or less I used you
guys to create a you know to create some
hype because we needed to put pressure
and it's like like that guy is such a
scumbag Q Anon grifter and he was going
on there doing that [ __ ] and that makes
sense if because David Knight does
strike me as a guy that would go no this
is [ __ ] like you know are are we or
are we not the good guys like or do we
need to sell dick pills like I I kind of
believe a certain angle I do believe
that David Knight would be out of all
the guys at Infowars he'd be the one
that's like this is stupid why are we
giving this guy air time so I don't know
yeah
um and so
David Knight
according to what Alex is saying was
sick of all the cue stuff now look maybe
Alex had these people on and he didn't
believe them and he just Alex to his
credit Will pretty much just have
anybody on
um but I have a feeling that David
knighting was more than just the queue
stuff right
um
maybe I don't know I mean it's it's like
look it's it's like any relationship
that ends
you know
there's there's always like the thing
that made the relationship end paganic
pagenic pochanic I don't know I know I
just hate names
um no you got the worst [ __ ] names
let's have the worst [ __ ] names say
every time you got to talk to Bali song
you like make some artwork and you got a
PayPal I'm like I don't even know your
money works oh my God and then when you
pay them like yeah because PayPal is
like 700 and 500 700 characters yeah and
then I gotta pay like it gets to convert
the US dollar into like mushnicks or
whatever the [ __ ] you people have over
there stop it
stops whatever people suck I hate Polish
people anyway you [ __ ] know what
you've done your names and your z's and
you C's and you're y's if I ever [ __ ]
see any of your books in the street I'm
gonna bury my fist in your bread basket
um
it's like the end of any relationship
where you um you have like people go
like oh they broke up because he cheated
on her and then it's like oh okay that's
the reason it broke up but then you
really find out like
the cheating was also part of like just
them hating each other and they were
already fighting and he you know he's
getting [ __ ] nagged every day about
he said he was going to clean out the
garage and like there's there's always
all of these elements you're not making
enough money so and so is not working
hard at like and then when the cheating
happens like oh they broke up because
you cheated and you go oh okay open and
shut case but you go well no that
relationship was already like you know
two out of four of the engines already
blew out and it was already losing
altitude so it wasn't that the cheating
blew up the plane the plane was gonna
hit the ocean anyway right so I'm sure
there were other factors but I do think
that part of it was the cue stuff and
and it is [ __ ] like you know like if if
you start
make it a big [ __ ] stink about the Q
stuff every day it's going to add to the
like Jesus Christ [ __ ] David guy
again with this [ __ ] like you know
if he wants to be the boss tell him
let's go [ __ ] start his own company
and you know like all that [ __ ] will
start to fester and then I'm sure it was
just I'm sure Alex looked at the books
at the end of the year and was like you
know we could probably just not have
David and I like we could afford that
I'm being censored and that's what hurt
says I never censored him he took what I
would say on air if it disagree with him
at censorship and it was so weird I've
even seen some of the shows where he
goes censorship was bad over there I
knew I'd be let go soon
in the name of Jesus Christ and all my
children ever since or David Knight he's
a liar he made that up on air and I see
him like a devil on his show now just he
all envious hateful deviling up there in
the name of Jesus I rebuke you David
Knight you're a liar I never censored
you and I'm not with you and you know
that and that's why I let him go because
he hated me and he hated Infowars and he
told me in his Studio that he didn't
want me on his show and he was ashamed
of us well good go away from us
but
wow I didn't think this was gonna get
that [ __ ] I didn't think that was
gonna get that [ __ ] oh boy that was
heated and personal and I didn't see
this I I saw some stuff coming out
eventually about this but I did not
expect this to just oh
I could probably get David on the show
you want me to try
yeah why not I'll get him up we'll talk
to him okay yeah I kind of believe Alex
on this I I do think this is a situation
where both people kind of think they're
right I think this is a situation where
honestly if you talk to both guys
they probably would both have valid
points you know but that last part feels
like Alex really feels like David Knight
she's straight up lying about him like
that's I don't think Alex is you're
right I agree with you I think both
people believe they're telling the truth
is this one this is one of those
situations where depending on which way
they see it they both believe that they
are telling the truth that they are the
ones that are
um
I don't think anyone's trying to be
deceitful I think both people are
butting heads here I'll I'll try to get
David on
um I can try to get Alex on again too I
don't know if he's going to want to talk
about the David Knight stuff but you
know what we could just get Harrison
Smith he's boring he'll tell us about
his swords
was he around Sarah's not even around I
haven't I haven't seen him around in a
while probably like like hiding in his
room with his headphones on like you do
when your parents are like abusive and
fight yeah he like went in his room and
like [ __ ] put his headphones on it
was like rocking out like Macaulay
Culkin at the beginning of the black and
white video yeah I would guess that
Harrison went up in his room while his
parents were fighting put headphones on
and listen to like
some real [ __ ] to like sunny day real
estate oh no no no no come on please
don't tell me stuff like that you want
to like
he's just a little sad
uh it says here David Knight doesn't
like talking about it he addressed it on
Twitter a few times and twice on his new
show well then it sounds like he doesn't
mind talking about it yeah it's like
a job of talking about it Mr D my money
says Harrison Smith was at the snack
machine trying to be invisible
oh and it's yeah of course damn it you
have one of those kind of dollars son of
a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what I'm not that hungry I
don't care he just drops the Dollar on
the phone 10 minutes folding it to get
it perfect puts it in and then it goes
It goes in and out even less you ever do
that where you get the pill even better
and put it in and then it goes and
you're like it's even better than it was
[ __ ] oh no and you [ __ ] a man that's
all I'm thinking of poor Harrison oh
[ __ ] by the way and you know the vending
machine suck at him for worse because
it's all Infowars products of course
bone broth they just need to get some
[ __ ] super male vitality
hey Alex can we have like maybe one spot
in the machine that's like Snickers I
don't know Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
Snickers turn you're gay yeah I'm not
having that globalist candy in my place
make our own candy have some bone broth
he just throws [ __ ] bone broth in his
head we're coming out with our own ice
cream bars Harrison that's right
unfortunately I lost a fortune because I
already had a bunch shipped out with
David knight's face on it son of a [ __ ]
make sure to listen to David Knight's
new show night wave spelled with a K
it's on it I also invested in a bunch of
ice cream bars with Trump's face on it I
was really really hopeful we were going
to win
now I just got a box of here so this ice
cream bar I think if we alter them
enough we can make them look like Biden
and I'll just send them back tell them I
don't know add some hair make them less
orange and less pedophiley even worse
that David Knight once he makes Harrison
Smith grow a beard
Harrison cold beard and gave 20 pounds
Harrison grow beard it better be better
than Crowders
all right Alex uh someone sent this clip
to Harrison please I want him to know
we're talking about him
uh
uh poor David Knight